we begin the day in south africa where
the rule of law for everyone
is under attack soldiers are now
patrolling the streets in many cities
after a day that saw the worst violence
in the country in years
looters set fire to shopping centers and
warehouses crowds clashed with
outnumbered police
more than 40 people have died many say
the violence is the result of high
unemployment made worse by the country's
anemic vaccination drives
there is also the feeling that 27 years
after apartheid
many promises made by corrupt
politicians have not been kept
south africa's political leaders
certainly shoulder a lot of the blame
including former president
jacob zuma but he does not see it that
way
zuma is behind bars tonight two weeks
ago the country's highest court
sentenced him to 15 months in prison for
contempt of court
after he refused to appear before a
panel investigating corruption
allegations against him
zuma says this is all a political
witch-hunt
equating the decisions of the high court
with the system of justice under
apartheid today his foundation issued a
threat
if zuma is not released from prison
there will be no peace in south africa
is this what it looks like and what it
sounds like
is former south african president jacob
zuma holding his own
country hostage we begin tonight with
this report
this warehouse in durban was ransacked
by hundreds of people
the shelves emptied the goods carried
out in bulk
it is only one of dozens of malls
supermarkets and small shops that were
targeted by looters
like this party supplies shop in soweto
it's over it's over i've got overheads
i've got i owe banks money
how am i going to pay this month with
what
in some instances armed local residents
went after the looters
themselves
the government sent soldiers to the most
affected areas as police struggled to
control the unrest
the current situation on the ground is
under strong surveillance
and we will ensure that it does not
deter
it any further we cannot allow anyone
to make a mockery of our democratic
state
the protest started last week after
former south african president jacob
zuma began serving a 15-month jail term
he was sentenced for contempt of court
after refusing to appear at a corruption
inquiry the outrage of zuma's supporters
was compounded by anger over persisting
inequality
and poverty in the country
and for more now i want to cross over to
our correspondent christine munoz she is
in cape town
covering the story for us good evening
to you christine
jacob zuma's foundation today said there
would be no peace
in south africa until zuma is released
from prison
is south africa is it being held hostage
tonight by its former president
well brent uh it would be very difficult
to argue that we are not here
because of the former president's
incarceration
um when mr zuma was facing imprisonment
his supporters warned that there would
be unrest in the country in fact when
they initially started mobilizing
there was a hashtag doing the rounds on
social media platforms
shut down south africa free jacob zuma
and of course we find ourselves where we
are today brent
beyond the looting that we have been
seeing happening
in these two key provinces is the
destruction
we're talking about the burning down on
certain properties
buildings assets it appears that there
are people hell-bent
on making a disruptive mark on this
country
doing significant damages to to certain
assets in this country and we've
certainly seen
how it is affecting the delivery of
products
key nerve centers that are responsible
for the transportation of goods across
the country
have actually been halted including
certain sites
where vaccine rollout has been suspended
people aren't able to get their vaccines
because of the extent of the damage that
is being done
in this country and you know we hear
that this was all sparked by the jailing
of former south african leader jacob
zuma
zuma though he turned himself into
police almost one week ago and the
violent reactions
which his supporters promised it feels
like they came somewhat delayed i mean
what does that tell us
well brent actually this actually
started a few hours after the president
the former president was uh arrested
we saw small groups of people and these
were isolated incidents
you had had the incident of a car
burning here a building satellite there
a small number of people
gathered in the name of free jacob zuma
but by the time we went to the weekend
this was a full-scale
arsenal attack saluting the kinds of
pictures that we're now looking at
um today so certainly we've heard it
from the security cluster the minister
of state security
coming out and saying that they are now
investigating
that former security officials that are
believed to be linked to the former
president
might be involved in this there is a
level of sophistication
that has taken course here and that is
what officials here
are investigating and i'm wondering this
unrest that is attached to his
incarceration um is that likely then to
impact his court case because he is
appealing you know the sentence of 15
months for contempt of court
well many people here especially those
in the legal fraternity would argue that
that has absolutely no
bearing uh on the on the mr zuma's
appeal case at the constitutional court
on monday and his lawyers spent the
better part of the day essentially
making their case as to why that court
uh should
reconsider its sentencing its judgment
and conviction
of the former president everybody who
was watching that case
from the legal expert side does not feel
that
mr zuma's lawyers made a convincing
enough case
uh that the hurdles that they needed to
get over to to get the poor to
to make that decision they don't appear
to have done that but it doesn't appear
that
the developments in the country today
will have any bearing on that particular
case
great there are soldiers on
some streets tonight in south africa
the military was the military deployed
to do
a job that the local police could not do
or would not do
that is essentially it and that has
caused outrage and this deployment
of the military although it is confined
to these two uh
provinces has really shown uh what is
a failure by law enforcement uh
people were warned in this country it
was clear to people that there would be
some kind of reaction
uh if the former president was
incarcerated so that was to be expected
the fact that for days on end you had
people
causing the damage that people have done
the extent of the looting destruction
and there was no law enforcement visible
in some cases for hours on end
and not a single police officer in sight
and now
you have a military presence which
itself is proving ineffective it is a
limited deployment
and it has done nothing to quell the
outbreak
and the unrest in this country we are
still seeing more looting
taking place even as i am speaking at a
number of locations
in the two affected provinces halden and
the guadalupe so certainly
south africans asking the questions
tonight that there has been a
failure when it comes to this country's
leadership the police ministers state
security officials
as well as the president very much in
the firing line and
under attack by the south african public
tonight brent yeah a disturbing
situation and we know that you will stay
on top of events for us christine
what in cape town tonight christine as
always thank you